[Musique]
il ya 50 ans disparaissait le général de
gaulle le président de la république
vous même le président de l'assemblée
chacun à sa manière a rendu hommage à
l'homme
celui qui sauva l'honneur à 40 celui qui
dans les années 60 rétabli notre
économie et nos comptes publics
celui qui dot à notre pays
d'institutions solides mais aussi
respectueuse des libertés en particulier
lorsqu'il fallut prendre des mesures
d'exception limitant les libertés
publiques
il veille à ce que ce soit le plus bref
possible nos compatriotes subissent ces
violences d'une minorité de jeunes
délinquants qui polluent leur quotidien
et saccagent impunément leur cadre de
vie
non nous n'avons pas affaire à des
incivilités
nous avons affaire à des délits les
délits particulièrement violent dans le
but de dégrader de casser de blessés
face à ces scènes inadmissible nos
concitoyens attendent des réponses
fermes rapide et déterminée ils
attendent des actes et non du discours
je tiens à vous dire que malheureusement
les atteintes à la laïcité le
communautarisme en gangréné certaines
écoles certains collèges certains lycées
aussi monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
lors de la loi sur le séparatisme pour
les éradiquer le vaccin n'est pas encore
disponible mais la stratégie
d'approvisionnement se décide et se
mette en oeuvre maintenant après le
manque criant de masques en mars
le manque criant de tests en avril il
serait incompréhensible que notre pays
sixième puissance mondiale manque de
vaccins contre lacko vide
monsieur le premier ministre ce que nous
voulons et là c'est le restaurateur qui
vous parle c'est travailler on est en
train de perdre notre patrie moindre
votre retraite
nous voulons pas être sous perfusion
bien sûr on a besoin des aides de l'état
mais nous voulons surtout travailler et
faire travailler dans le respect des
règles sanitaires et la santé de chacun
nous avons besoin d'un plan de
sauvegarde massif qui est spécifique à
ces secteurs
l'événementiel c'est un écosystème de
pme qui ne survivront pas si on ne les
aide pas et il y à là vraiment un rôle
collectif à jouer pour se sauver
ces pépites qui sont emblématiques de la
france le secteur de l'horticulture
représente 3300 entre
prise et 20000 emplois il pèse 1,64
milliard d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
mais l'horticulture française est
aujourd'hui en danger de mort
en effet le gouvernement français est le
seul en europe à avoir interdit la vente
de fleurs coupées tout créneau de
distribution confondus
une étude est relatée issus de nature's
qui nous apprend que tous les types de
commerce ne se valent pas
comme source de contamination et ne
présentent pas tous de risque sévère en
effet il ressort que libraire fleuristes
coiffeurs magasin de jouets tant
d'autres sont quinze fois moins
dangereux que d'autres catégories de
commerces ce qui tend à prouver une
certaine forme d'inutilité de vos choix
hétéroclite pris dans l'urgence sous la
pression d'un virus qui mène la danse
nous vous entendons très peu sur la
prise en compte des conséquences
humaines humaine de ces périodes de
déconfinement une bonne santé mentale
permet aux personnes de mieux surmonter
les tensions normal de la vie
mais en cette période de crise sanitaire
nous sommes confrontés à une situation
anormale contraindre toute une
population
pendant plusieurs semaines à limiter
voire interdire tout contact sociaux et
physique a inévitablement un impact
néfaste sur la santé mentale de tous
l'état doit assurer la liberté de culte
qui a rang dans leur pays de libertés
fondamentales votre décision de limiter
ce qui est essentiel à la fréquentation
des grandes surfaces a restreint cette
liberté fondamentale
la france qui joue un rôle moteur dans
la diplomatie européenne ne doit plus
attendre la branche politique et la
branche militaire du hezbollah sont
indissociables puisque dirigé par un
seul et même chef
nous ne devons plus être dans
l'ambiguïté avec cette seule
organisation terroriste n'est-il pas
temps monsieur le ministre que la france
prenne les mesures qui s'imposent pour
mettre le hesbollah hors jeu pour
envoyer un message de fermeté à l'iran
est constitué de nos alliés européens
américains et arabes
un front uni pour combattre enfin le
terrorisme et l'islamisme avec la
lucidité et les moyens appropriés
hélas dans le domaine international
comme dans bien d'autres les actes
suivent rarement les paroles
présidentielles et c'est bien par un
manque de résultats et par une
succession d'échecs
que s'est traduite la relation entre la
france et les états unis sur tous les
dossiers clés pour emmanuel macron
[Musique]